This is the all new Nike Vapormax.
190 dollar running shoe that took 7 years
to make.
The upper is pretty standard Nike, but the
sole is, well, it's different.
There's no foam, there's no rubber, just a
system of air bladders.
These sneakers may well be the future of the
company, but are they any good?
We took them for a spin to find out.
So these things look like space ships but
otherwise the NASA factor is kinda low honestly.
On a run, the shoe doesn't feel drastically
unique.
It's not like bouncing on a trampoline or
running on a water bed mattress.
And it's the subtle things that kinda stand
out.
They're really light.
And they're more flexible than they look.
There's also a good bit of pop, but it doesn't
feel synthetic, and the bounce is mostly in
the heel.
Someone who tends to run striking with the
middle or the front of their foot won't even
notice that much.
Maybe the most impressive thing is that these
little jellyfish bladders didn't pop like
water balloons when we came down hard on a
curb or a subway grate.
Another selling point is durability.
The air bladders are filled with nitrogen,
which, unlike foam cushioning, won't break
down.
So the shoes can theoretically go a lot farther
than 500 miles, which is kinda the standard
life of a running shoe.
Finally the sole is modular- look for nike
to start monkeying with these airpods to make
versions that are more minimal, more cushioned,
more firm, etc.
In truth, how vapormax sneakers perform on
a run isn't as important as one might think.
Three quarters of athletic shoes never see
a track or a field, they're bought for the
street, the style if you will.
They're bought more often for walking.
These sneakers do that just fine.